The good part about this topic is that the types of questions
you will see are very few and repetitive.
One Category is that of forming numbers.
We will be given a few digits, and will be asked to form numbers.
For example, with these six digits we could be asked
of how many three-digit numbers we can form.
Next, we might be asked to form anagrams.
Here, we will be given a word, a word like 'SILENT'.
And asked for the number of anagrams
we can form with these six letters.
An anagram of a word can be formed by simply rearranging its letters.
An Anagram of 'SILENT' would be 'LISTEN'.
Another anagram would be 'ESITLN'. And what does it mean?
Nothing, it's a meaningless anagram. It won't work in Scrubber.
Another category of problems would be that of arranging people.
We could be asked the number of ways,
in which we can see people on four chairs.
Or maybe arrange them around a circular table.
So in this session, and the next few, we will be looking at the first category.
Arranging digits to form numbers.
Let's say we have these five digits with us, and this is what we're asked!
Read the question well. How many
three digit numbers can be formed?
Let's form three slots here for the three digits.
How many three-digit numbers can be form using these five digits?
And with this question, we have been given two conditions.
First, it asks us the answer when repetition is not allowed.
Let us understand the first condition!
Repetition is not allowed.
Look at the number '1 1 1'.
This is a three-digit number, but the digit 1 is repeated.
Look at '2 3 2' or '5 4 4'.
The digit 2 is repeated here. And the digit 4 is repeated here.
By repetition not being allowed,
they mean that numbers like these should not be considered.
Each of the digits in the slot should be different. So numbers like 123,
341 or 524 are allowed as the digits in each case
are different from each other.
So let's make 3 slots for the digits again.
Now you can start thinking.
How many three-digit numbers can be formed
if repetition is not allowed?
Before you think of the three-digit numbers, look at the slots individually.
Let's look at the first slot or the hundreds place.
In how many ways can you fill the first slot?
It is a simple question. You don't need to know
permutations or combinations for this.
In how many ways can you fill the first slot?
You can fill it with any of the five digits right?
You can fill it with a 1 or a 2 or a 3 or a 4 or a 5.
These are the five digits given to us.
Did you listen carefully? I use the word or.
1 or a 2 or a 3 and so on.
So 5 ways and all .
We can fill it with any one of these five digits.
Okay,
now listen to the next question carefully.
Having filled the slot with one of the digits.
In how many ways can we fill the second slot?
Easy!
We have used one of the digits here, it can be any digit doesn't matter.
But after having used one,
four digits remain. So the second slot can be filled in four ways.
If we fill the first slot with one.
We have two, three, four, five as possibilities here.
If we fill the first slot with three
we have one, two ,four, five as the possibilities for the second slot.
Now tell me having filled the first and the second slot
in how many ways can the third slot be filled?
It's simple.
We have used up two digits here only three remain.
The third slot can be filled in three ways.
We're almost done. Almost.
The first slot can be filled in five ways.
The second and four ways and the third in three ways.
So how many three-digit numbers
can be formed if repetition is not allowed?
Do we add these three or do we multiply them?
What are we doing?
I'll be filling in the first slot or the second slot or the third slot?
Or are we filling in the first slot
and the second slot and the third slot. It will be and.
Yes, we are filling all three slots and not just one.
And, as we have seen in the previous session is
multiplication.
So we multiply these three.
Five times four is 20. And 20 times 3 is 60.
There are 60 ways in which we can form three-digit numbers,
without repetition of digits.
These include numbers like 123, 314 ,245 and so on.
No repetition.
Hope this was clear,
Here we started off with the hundredths place.
Can we start off with the units place?
Of course yes, we could have.
If we would have started off with the units place,
we could say that the units place could be filled in five ways.
Once the Units place is filled
the tens place would be filled with any of the remaining four digits .
And once two digits are utilized.
The hundredths place can be filled with any one of the remaining three digits.
Three times four times five, will also give us the same answer.
60 Ways.
If you really understood this,
then understanding the second stated condition would be super easy.
Let's repeat the question on a new page.
This time we solve the question keeping in mind the second condition.
Given these five digits.
How many three-digit numbers can be formed assuming repetition is allowed?
So now we are allowed to consider numbers like 111 or 322 and so on.
So we have three slots for the three digits.
How many three-digit numbers can be formed when repetitions
are allowed?
I want you to try this.
Remember, repetitions are allowed.
So now we are allowed to consider all numbers,
which we had ignored earlier.
We should have the possible numbers greater than 60.
Try it !
Okay, as we saw earlier. Let's go slot by slot.
In how many ways can the hundredths place be filled.
It can be filled with any one of the five digits we have.
It can be filled in five ways.
Now in how many ways can the second slot be filled?
Think well, the second slot can also be filled in five ways.
Why? It's because repetitions are allowed.
If we used up one digit here,
The same one can be used here as well.
So no matter what digit is used in the hundreds place
the tens place can be filled with any one of the five digits
we have been given.
And similarly,
the third slot can also be filled with any one of the five digits.
Five ways again.
If we have one in the hundreds place.
The same one can be used in the tens place.
And in the units place as well.
There are no restrictions here.
So as we are filling in the first and the second and the third slot.
We multiply these three numbers and get the answer as 125 ways.
What does this answer imply relative to the previous one?
Let's go back and see the previous answer.
If repetition wasn't allowed.
There were 60 ways in which we can form three-digit numbers.
And if repetition is allowed there are 125 ways.
Why has the number increased?
It's obvious.
Here, apart from the no repetition ones like 123, 314, 245.
We have allowed numbers like
111, 222, 434 and many more like them to be considered.
So I hope both cases are clear!
Repetition allowed, and not allowed.
Which case do you think is easier to solve?
Think.
It is the repetition allowed case.
We don't have to worry about any of the conditions given.
It makes life really easy,
and you will realize why when you watch the further sessions.